[Music]
yeah i think that's you they they they
did to her too and um no no you know
what no no no no you know who that was
no
no
what
got disconnected hey yeah sorry about
that uh we're kind of doing our show
live right now the same time we do every
day
oh i feel like such an [ __ ] i
couldn't imagine why
um could i get back to you i don't know
when we're not on the air live
i want to punch myself
i'm so [ __ ] sorry yeah well i'll call
you don't go punching yourself but let's
just let's let's you know put this off a
little bit i'll literally buy you a
[ __ ] plane ticket to punch me in the
head nah that's fine
that's that's just that's fine
yeah it's cool
um it's fine you don't have to buy any
plane tickets but we'll we'll give you a
call we'll
talk about um maybe i don't know getting
paid what we used to get paid and agreed
on at some point um i'll talk to you a
little bit all right man i gotta go
we're not doing the show
[Music]
no problem
[Music]
[ __ ] kidding me man
oh no you're [ __ ] kidding me man
our ad guy who loves the show
loves it can't stop telling us
how much he loves the goddamn show
just doesn't know what time it's on
it doesn't want to pay us the amount of
money we agreed on in the original
[ __ ] deal
i can't breathe give me a second i'm
sorry i had to do that you know why i
had to right i get it i'm not one of the
funniest things i've ever seen
should i timestamp this too yep
and there's frozen i love you forever
that's why you're keeping around buddy
should i timestamp this too
i mean no no cause now i'm [ __ ] he
was mad the other day now i'm mad so
it's no no no no no it's it's not enough
to cut our money without ever notifying
us that our money's cut
right
but then called during the live show
oh my god it's like god it's like you
pissed in my face
and then got in your car and started
driving home and you got three exits
away and then you pulled the u-turn and
went oh man i forgot to smear [ __ ] in
his eyes
i gotta turn around now wasting all this
gas
i feel better
hey go to mybookie.ag to see how much
longer we have advertisers
oh he's not going anywhere
i'm just
[ __ ] kidding me
and um
hmm i got a cat with aids you should
[ __ ] pay us what you owe us
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm sick of this [ __ ]
man
a cat with aids
i have a cat with aids oh [ __ ] christ
you see everyone you know what's so
funny too this is why i get the rep is
the mean one
everyone says royce is the nice one and
he's not i was really angry on
yesterday's show no no but i just mean
in general when dealing with people all
right royce has the rep of being the
nice one
but it's always because when it comes
time to blow up royce is just like yeah
no i have at it
i'm usually the one going are you
serious
i feel better now see because i was just
kind of making a joke of it the other
day
and royce was mad and i was having fun
but man that script flipped so fast
[Laughter]
all right
all right
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]